it's the fighter and the kid had to run
it back cause we back at it again yeah
we gon keep it moving like it's never
gonna end when it was brendan when it
was brian when he was just talking to
friends we got the kid calling on the
left with the fighter on the right had
to do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is really the fighter and the kid
we're out come on baby
well we got a little pee-pee on my pants
i know you're pee-pee on your pants a
little bit and you said that you went
a little bit you know when you put it
back in yep put the snake back in you're
not done yet
the drip but it was
more than drip that's what happens i
i'll i'll put it back in and he's he's
like i wasn't dumped yeah he's going
you're like oh if i was in a really cold
area i might die i would i would freeze
to death my dick would fall it's
uncomfortable yeah you can't tell these
jeans though yeah but there is a little
bit of a stain isn't there i mean you
can't really tell i can from here oh you
can definitely definitely tell that
sounds like
it's like oh right right because we're
in the middle of conversation i wasn't
painting but was that because you put it
you put it back in and you piss through
it yes oh okay i thought i was done no
you weren't done i wasn't paying
attention then just like let's put this
can't rush
back in the can yeah you can't rush the
snake went i'm not done i'm not done
that's the problem with rushing
everything there was a there was a guy
my acting teacher used this as an
example whether it's true or not and he
said you know
got to take your time guys you guys are
rushing through these scenes and my
friend i i i
she was such a dear friend of mine
and she was coming to visit me
and she had been in michigan the winter
was horrible and spring was here and she
was going to come to new york and we had
such a great time i had everything
planned i had all these shows lined up
and everything else and uh she died and
everybody goes whoa
and what happened he goes she was eating
a piece of meat and she didn't chew it
and she choked and died in her [ __ ]
house so the point of the story is don't
rush she was
oh wow yeah the state guy all of us were
like well
hey how about a better example
tough piece of me i feel like we haven't
been in here not what two weeks
it's taking a little time off you and i
were both in montana mm-hmm so lots a
lot's transpired i mean i was in yeah i
was on montana was there tuesday through
friday yeah yeah i had a really good
weekend i i
thursday i practically sell out wise
guys it's a thursday night i love that
one show or two shows one show salt lake
city all good and then
rogan hits me up and says
come to my show
come see this oh cause he's in salt lake
city for the ufc and doing shows he
wasn't playing wise guys though no they
don't know he was playing
the maverick center now that the center
the maverick center and when you play
the center you gotta understand as i was
going there i go what's all this traffic
why am i stuck in this oh it's my friend
they're coming to see 14 000 people
is this where the jazz play
uh
you know what sure
sure yeah i don't well it's twelve
thousand people that would make sense
twelve thousand i could
and he's in the he's in the round so
he's in the middle of all of them
and uh
i i have to say that he's he's firing on
all cylinders mr rogan yes and i think
this next special is going to be uh
unbelievable now
i've ever seen him do the best thing
i've ever seen please play there
interesting probably the best hour i've
seen and i don't know how long oh wow
all [ __ ] i think i told you now
could daddy have put you on stage though
could brian jump up there i'm sure he
would not then sure he would have the
the thing is tony
it's it's a well-oiled machine when
you've got that many people there's a
time thing is the asian fellow who's
hilarious he's very funny tony tony
crushed it
that's it it's the show you don't want
to do you do another third
and you're there's a timer you know yeah
and also excuses it was last minute yeah
oh that's true yeah it was it was last
minute and then rogan probably does over
an hour he does he does almost exactly
an hour he finds that doing more than
that is a little bit much 100 percent
you know with 12 000 way too much yeah
yeah but god damn that hour god damn
that hour it was fun huh
he's got it all dialed in no you're
dialed in boom now you and i are gonna
fly to austin
we're gonna fly to awesome i don't know
if we're supposed to say that right now
oh i mean i think he wants to keep that
oh really in secret okay
yeah but either way you and i'll fly to
austin do something that's all i'm gonna
say we're gonna do something mm-hmm a
little teaser and do you said i told you
you missed uh two fight campaigns over
the weekend i did with the great burke
chrysler four-hour fight campaign wow
because we did bare knuckle fighting
i've never you know i've never watched a
full car mike perry fought in that mike
perry michael van page but they have won
that they have a lot of fights on that
card dude a lot of fights i like ufc
five too many maybe
i think so like i think next time we'll
tell you know bkfc hey we're just doing
the last five yeah we can't do whatever
it is how did michael then and paige do
in baron what do you think one bro what
do you think won
i would oh i would give the i would say
definitely michael venom page
but you would just not but he's not
allowed to kick nope and so it's a
different distance than he's used to
maybe i mean also mike is a hearty dude
so it's just tough like a lot of that
bear knuckles just toughness i i think
with michael vin and paige you know he's
more of a fragile more i'm not fragile
but not fragile he's beat some monsters
he's more of a technician that's more
you know brawling and that's mike
perry's game so he beat him his decision
yeah he beat him they went five rounds
and then they gave did about six rounds
why is michael venom page doing bare
knuckle fighting why not why did they
not why did they never bring him into
the ufc well he's with bellator i know
he's making too much money in military
he's just he's with bellator so he can't
so he's still there he's still there
yeah the uh bellator allowed him to do
this one-off with bin uncle the only
person who saw him get beat him was that
lima guy but everybody yes he just beat
the [ __ ] out of everybody else so
exciting but mike perry you know just
pressured and made ugly and won the
fight dropped in the first round through
wow mike perry's a dog yeah but then you
see how tough michael venom page is too
if you can take that kind of beating get
dropped and kind of it wasn't a beating
it was just it was just like a brawl you
know not a beating yeah
the fights were that luke rockhold fight
was just like i don't know if people
know but his nose got shattered
so he was breathing in that altitude
he'd only been up in that altitude for
three days
and
and and then
he was breathing through his [ __ ]
mouth
that's not fun but he's still just going
[ __ ] you boom
i think if he's acclimated
in that fight you run that fight back i
think he wins where's retiring right yes
yeah he's retired and part of the reason
i think he didn't i don't think he wins
i i i
you don't
i love luke roccold you know those i
think he's i think he's also yeah but
gone tell me yeah it's the end of the
road for him he's older his body wasn't
far enough cylinders
i think the notion that altitude was the
reason why he was breathing so hard and
fatigued is
not an excuse um luke knows this i he
you know it came out you know bisping
talked to jason perello he didn't spar
or train that well first of all he
couldn't spar
i didn't know this came out because i
wasn't saying but
he he he because of his leg and stuff he
just wasn't able to spar so he that was
luke going in there not even being able
to spar just having to be conditioned
you're gonna get tired there's only one
way to get in fight shape and that's by
fighting right doing all the running and
it doesn't matter grappling no you gotta
i would see guys who are like
competitive triathletes like ranked
triathletes come in the box oh different
animals this guy this guy was with
literally after one round couldn't
breathe and fell just different yeah
yeah so for for luke it's
you know but being in shape is number
one thing but
you know i just think he's end of the
road you look at the way also he was
like the the comments he's making the
press conference and stuff like that
like he was like
i think mentally he was like he's
probably the last one yes [ __ ] it let's
burn the house down exactly and i
enjoyed it me too i think the fight was
sloppy you know and like i said on the
companion the guys who are ranked you
know six or seven are foaming at the
dick to fight paulo or luke now yeah
you're like oh this is easy money yes
you know well but he's just older like
you remember luke you know for a hot
second he had the injuries and whatever
the other layoff but you when he was in
his primary one wouldn't the best ever
do it i think one of the best ever so
without question like
and chelsea was saying that about him
being like he's in that conversation
nobody talks about best middleweight
ever no not a lot but
well anderson silva yes he he's up there
with all those guys i think
i mean i think he's not ashamed silva
but if you look at who he's beaten like
tim kennedy
[ __ ] jacare i mean ever he he fought
all comers but yeah when strikeforce is
a monster yeah i mean you know he he's
chris weidman he's doing the best to do
it for sure
monster monster
but it was i thought it was a good way
to go out in a lot of ways i thought it
was just yeah i thought he finally got
like the accolades he deserves you know
talk about a guy he gets a lot of hate
you know because the way he looks and
he's very brash and arrogant but we know
him and he's not really that way that's
kind of a character so great yeah he's
the best yep
yeah he's good and then uh
leon edwards dude
nuts
he was just i was ready i'm like all
right 50 seconds left let me get the
[ __ ] out of here yeah i'm like i've been
podcast for seven hours i'm ready to get
the [ __ ] out yeah boom
leonard said hold my two-piece and soda
check this out yeah i mean i'm with
rogan anak everyone greatest knockoff of
all time hands down yeah i mean never
better astonishing
you know the best ever do it in his
prime and if you would have won would
have broke anderson silva's all-time
defense record yes
was so on his way to winning insane you
know so on his way to winning and that's
that's 54 seconds yeah just secretly
you're such a dangerous [ __ ]
just a dangerous he's always dangerous i
guess great [ __ ] around yeah that's why
the sport's so great god that was insane
though wasn't it nuts oh it was
astonishing it was just like what the
[ __ ] is going on here yo what's going on
what is going on because that card was
but luke's fight was fun with costo that
was the probably the funnest fight in
the card i mean come on i said this
leaning into him like it's not gonna be
a fun fight like camaro's gonna hold him
down like get him against the cage and
strike with him a ton
leon won that first round with the trip
we got to mount didn't do much right
then you get three
well you get three
more than almost four rounds of him home
against cage take him down not doing a
ton yeah and then just
what just slip this for a second hey
real quick can you lean
i think he punched with this hand and
then he threw a jab he threw a jab and
then
come on
with the same hand as the so his back
foot was back and he threw it put it in
his he went blinded him with it yeah bob
and then oh you're going to slip get
that kind of same thing that happened to
daniel cormier with uh with jon jones
where he slipped
to the right
boom right into the brood
it's like taking a batch oh
leon edwards i i i i think that that the
rematch
what's interesting about when a champion
gets knocked out especially a champion
it's great and dominant like amanda
nunes
opinion then they go
oh hell no they come back so one of two
things happens
one
and i i'm gonna tell you what i think
but one of two things happened one is
there's a fighter who gets your number
and because you got knocked out for
whatever reason
you're not quite the same i don't think
some i'm saying wait but then then there
are fighters like commander nunez who go
hola oh
what the [ __ ] just happened huh uh you
got lucky there okay i got some i'm
gonna take you seriously yeah and then
they got my attention now you got my
attention i'm coming i think that's i
think that's 100 the case with usman
however how long has this moment
fighting he he too has always rumbled a
little bit about the idea that maybe
he's getting you know his knees
he has bad knees but also he
there hasn't been a lot of competition
from like leon was the last one hamzad
if he beats nate there's that if you
want to beat that young lion see that
fight but he's like he's talking about
going to light heavyweight
because because he's
beat everybody so now
you know all right i'm not gonna light
heavyweight you gotta beat leon but i
also think there's a chance that's not
an immediate rematch because i think if
i'm camaro's team
um we're not finding february that's a
he takes a bad knockout he takes leon
can fight you know in two months so i
think what they're gonna do is like a
leon verse
mazvidal leon rich colby something like
that
mozville would be good kobe i'd rather
see the colby me too moswell didn't make
any sense but for the fans it makes
sense i'd love that fight yeah but you
can't give muscle on that leon and kobe
be great to watch
that'd be really really fun i think kobe
gets the belt and then has to fight
tomorrow it'd be fun huh
oh yeah so and also if you're leon
edwards fan like
you know just history shows you know i
think he's a plus 275 underdog already
in the trilogy
chancellor is not gonna win that fight
the chance of him landing that kick
again on camaro over 25 minutes you got
to solve you got to solve that wrestling
problem and you're he's doing all day
have you gonna have your legs taken from
under you come on took his eye off the
yeah clogged for one second so [ __ ] off
welcome to big leagues that's how it
goes man that's how good people are
that's right like you're like oh leon's
not that good no no no no no no no no no
no no
no no
he is no camaro is that good he made it
look like
leon wasn't that good yeah and he
literally just let his guard down for
nano seconds and got
head kick kale he's never been knocked
out before ever good god ever good guy
never lost in the fc
wow
that's so nuts welcome to the game
welcome to the game the game player one
oh dude you know what aired last night
was uh house of dragons baby
really you have no clue no i know all
about it yeah yeah but i've been i've
been wondering
what give me your reviews well i went in
as a hater as well you should know i'm
deep and deep i love me some game don't
tell me about game of thrones yeah i
know i don't know i don't know
six years and i refuse i think it's a
great show of all time hands down that's
like saying i love you this is a great
phone it's better than me yeah that
blackberry yeah i i even like season
eight that's how balls do but i'm in
game of thrones love it so when it
started i was kind of hating i'm like it
doesn't really look like game of thrones
and my girl was like would you shut the
[ __ ] up and just watch it
20 minutes in i was like oh my god
it's [ __ ] good really oh dude it's so
you need something to watch oh me too
like i'm i'm
40 i'm on my 47th episode of love island
the new season uk that's my favorite
show shout out to luca but then on
[ __ ] house of dragons it and what you
know i like you know what i
enjoy about it too it you can't binge
watch it you have to appreciate and
build up the hype to the following
sunday hbo is going we're not netflix
you're going to wait every sunday for
this to come out and i appreciate that
because i would have been up to three in
the morning finishing that series and
then you don't appreciate it enough
right like i wish stranger things was
like that i rushed through it then i
have nothing to look forward to and they
can't keep coming out with these huge
shows non-stop right it takes time it
takes time and the time is where it's at
dude yes so for for a house of dragons
oh so you're giving it is it as good as
oh it's up there daddy right away you're
on board and then also you know the back
story because no i don't know what's not
i'm saying it takes it's a prequel so i
think it's 300 years before all the game
of thrones [ __ ] happens so they're
referencing like the white walkers and
they're them coming they think they're
coming but they don't come for whatever
300 years yeah from there but they are
preparing for that and just those
nuggets and the dragons you're like [ __ ]
yeah dude
and the dragon
the dragon's bad oh it's dope dude
because the dragons when we were
introduced to them they were they were
being held captive
under the castle oh not now now they're
flourishing they're out there now they
ride them like ubers now now mother of
dragons she's far from being born that's
a whole different thing way yeah this is
uh this is the beginning of the dragons
no they've they've been the family but
it's interesting because the king has to
uh
uh
say who his next ear is and he wanted a
son but he only has daughters so they
have this little badass girl and she's
the next heir but he's never given her
attention she's not a a boy yeah and
then fire you know i don't spoil it
finding he has to give her the air well
and then he tells her you know he's like
do you know what makes us
special and she's like yeah you know we
we have dragon blood like you know we
ride dragons and she's like but we're
not special we're just we're only
special because we have the dragons if
we don't have dragons we're just like
every other man he's like correct [ __ ]
it's so good dude i'm telling you i take
stop filming because these boys aren't
the ones that wrote it i said they're
not the ones no it's not the original
writers from the original because the
original one was taken from the books
house of fire and ice or something yeah
but
the guys who produced directed the the
game of thrones on uh hbo or todd's guys
yeah and they're not involved with this
capacity is it but it is hbo it's still
hbo so still a huge budget so it's a new
writer dude it's so good god damn i text
i'm like you know you don't hear this i
give it an a-plus
it was [ __ ] dope it will it will
definitely
you know cure your appetite if you're if
you're sad about not seeing dragons and
right you know
oh it's good wow oh it's good dude how
was montana montana was the best the
best the best
i was i was there
hot
i don't know if i'm going in the summer
anymore it is hot it was like you know i
live in the valley so it's [ __ ] hot
out there it is hot what did you guys do
i mean you named it you rode horses my
son was [ __ ] mr horse
it's weird how much my kids love horses
because i'm i've always been scared of
them yes as well and you should be i've
always been terrible and you should be
that's the greatest picture ever
you should frame that look how little he
is what's he saying there oh he's not he
kept saying he keeps calling uh horses
cowboys oh god
how old is he now
two
so [ __ ] cute with that little hat
it's it's and what's you know most kids
don't want to wear hats and [ __ ] he'd
love the [ __ ] hat he just wanted to
be in the house you guys with your hats
in there yeah did you buy those hats
there no we've had them let's take it
let's take it can we take a break
sometimes you gotta take a break i'll
tell you what you don't want to take a
break from working out necessarily you
don't and you but you need a break from
life you need to laugh so come to
appleton wisconsin september 8th through
the 10th and then come to ontario improv
september 15th the 17th and then take
another break boston because i'm in
boston september 29th october 1st go to
thinkboy.com man get a break come
outside your boy listen if you're in
raleigh north carolina maybe you want to
take a break maybe september 8th 9th or
10th get a break see some comedy come to
raleigh's at good nights maybe san jose
california improv september 15 16 17 of
spakan washington can washington comedy
club september 22 23 and 24 i'm just
saying get a break yeah or go to youtube
and watch best stuff which we're gonna
drop two more episodes up very soon here
but i need to get some exercise and i'm
getting tired of the gym dude i just
want to do something at home maybe can
you help me out i want my legs in shape
maybe i want to do some boxing maybe i
want to do some strength training and
some cardio what do you got for me dude
i like to listen to music but you don't
want to go to a gym you want to do that
mix it up and i like to have a coach
there and i know it costs a fortune so
what do i i don't know maybe i should
hire a coach no no dad dj can i get a dj
in the corner no no no you need peloton
bro your boy here has a telephone bike
and i have the tele tele
peloton yeah
no it's pellets
yeah but i want world class instructors
i want to keep it fresh i mean like
robin she's fantastic man you got to
keep it fresh they have thousands
on-demand live classes ranging from
cycling which i do they have strength
training yoga running if you have the
the treadmill it's fun dude and the
music daddy yeah what i want your
favorite artists on the playlist are
fantastic it's easy it fits into your
lifestyle if you're a busy one like me
it fits right in you get a great i want
but i want i want cycling i want
strength training i want yoga i'm
running i can't just be on a bike and
hot music you don't need a dj dude
peloton got you covered man thousands of
classes live on demand you can find a
workout that fits in your day maybe
you're looking for a 10 minute upper
body stretch b maybe a 30 minute run
before bed maybe
with your schedule man wherever you
happen to be at home at the gym even on
the road whatever peloton got you
covered man all you got to do if you
want something that's ready to go
anytime anywhere try peloton bike or
tread risk free for 30 days learn more
at peloton dot com new members only
terms apply that's one peloton.com
listen you know those times when you're
so into what you're doing you can't
think about anything else the times when
you're at your most focused and
productive all right psychologists call
that feeling of being in the zone or
what we call the fight game flow state
that's right flow state where you're
just feeling the vibes man and alpha
brain from on it is the ultimate way to
get there don't you want to get in that
flow state more cool what if i told you
take a little pill and it's going to get
you there a world-renowned nootropic
supplement with over 1 million bottles
sold alpha brain promotes cognitive
functions including memory mental speed
and focus can help you remember names
zero in on complex tasks whatever you're
trying to do if you're under stress we
got you covered man our boy joe rogan
says he feels that it helps him form
better sentences when he's talking
so that you know it's gonna help you out
if it helps out mr joe rogan it's gonna
help you out helps me out helps brian
out everybody on that alpha brain alpha
brain contains amino acids
and plant compounds that promote the
brain's release of alpha waves which are
associated with greater creativity
productivity at the same time it
supports neurotransmitters chemicals
that rely information in and from the
brain it's important if coffee and
energy drinks make you jittery or keeps
you up at night all good man alpha brain
is caffeine free baby but if for any
reason you don't like alpha brain guess
what you get your money back yep just
give us two weeks if at any point you
don't feel like alpha brain is a fit for
you just tell us why they'll refund your
money man no return necessary save 10
off your first order of alpha brain by
going to on it dot com slash f a t k
that's on it dot com f a t k
all right or swing by your local walmart
and pick some up today we got you man on
it alpha brain honor.com
f-a-t-k by the way montana you get there
so i was up from kalispell i went to our
boy annie stumps wedding
which i'll tell you about but we get
there and uh in the gift shop when you
get there in the gift shop is bear spray
and and there are grizzlies uh
everywhere i text you you're there
for me to scare with the bears you my
son are on uh uvt's i think view atvs no
no atvs is four wheel motors like the
motorcycles yeah this is the dune
buggies the the ut x bipolars wow polars
yeah so you're you're like you know it's
getting like a big ass there they are
like the can-am defender the polish rz
right there that's what we're wearing
the polar that's right right there so
we're in those but they're beefier too
yeah so it's me and my son and there's
like eight other
couples right and then there's a
guy who leads the way and you guys are
all driving those we're driving those
yeah right we're driving those and we're
going through you and we're in the
middle of nowhere in the mouth and they
can take they can they can alter bro i
mean we're there's no pat we're going up
the mountain my son's laughing his ass
off right we're going through water
splashing while we're having so much fun
where was this in montana where uh about
an hour outside missoula okay in the
middle of nowhere we're in the [ __ ]
mountains right yeah so we're going
my son's sick so of course you ask wild
questions like are there polar bears
sharks snakes whatever you know it's
like no there's nothing there's no
montana there's no rattlesnakes in my
town is that true no it's not so we're
going
and uh
we're coming back down
and because you go all the way up it's
about two hours up the mountain and you
know hour and a half down like you take
this weird scenic route down but you get
to the top and there's a ghost town
where it's one of the first mining towns
and it's just exactly how they left it
they've like upkeeped it but it's so
cool like so old school there's this guy
called two guns that you go by where he
lived on the river that's what's
interesting you left this so would they
stop there and he's like this is two
guns and he did this and he lived here
you know secluded that's why he liked it
here and he was a montana favorite he's
kind of a legend and he died in 2003 of
cancer blah blah and the lady goes uh
the the guide goes yeah he was a uh
what's known as a squatter and she goes
and the rules in montana
is
uh if you squat on a property for seven
years legally and monte it's yours
wow it's just the government's like all
right you've been long enough it's yours
the land everything is yours so a lot of
people have land from squatting she was
but then blm came along
and uh they they're on it now bm and she
kept going blm blm and i'm i'm like
looking at him like
and she goes so
blm is on it now so now they used to
check every few years now they check i
know every week and out and i was like a
question from the whole group real quick
you keep saying blm um i'm from l.a and
she goes oh my god i don't even think
about it of course you are she goes blm
is the bureau of blame management
management yeah she goes oh no and i was
like oh for saying i was like holy [ __ ]
blm's taking over montana real estate
this is an issue yeah i was like dude
this is a real i was like do you know
their background this is an issue she
could they couldn't stop laughing like
listen where i come from blm stands from
way different she's like oh my god you
quit saying that mark's historical yeah
don't use blm you like use the actual
name of it she started laughing she was
saying that two guns guy because of
squatting rules
20 miles away
the unabomber ted kazinski oh [ __ ] 20
miles away that's it and i said that's
such a remote location that's why i said
well let's drive these to the unibombers
thing she's like absolutely not [ __ ]
i'm like well that'd be i'd love to see
that yeah she's like they knocked it
down yeah but he
got in he owned that property because of
squatting wow he was there for over
seven years
got the property so the government
doesn't touch it they said it was so
remote that when the fbi stalked
staked him out
when they staked them out it was so
remote that they watched a cougar stalk
and kill a deer while you know so
they're looking at the unabomber and
they're so bored there's nothing and
they were it was so remote that that
they go there's a cougar and he barely
came out like he's always out there
cooking a bomb it [ __ ] kills a deer
and they're like at least that's
something entertaining to watch so we're
coming back down right from the thing
and the guy the guy in front of me
because i was directed behind him with
my son he kept pointing kept going like
this what the [ __ ] is he pointing i look
i see two little bear cubs
[ __ ] flight like going up the
mountain and i'm like oh [ __ ]
naturally i go oh [ __ ] those are bear
cubs they don't roll so low
mama bears somewhere nearby they're not
far from us no he stops and we i can't
go past him as a single [ __ ] track
he stops he goes dude check out the two
bear cubs cool cool hey do you have a
gun excuse me do you have a gun he goes
no
why are we stopping this dude once
whenever you've ever seen a burial
on tv dude
those cubs the mama's around there
somewhere he's like right am i and you
don't have a gun bear spray nothing else
i go i'm with my son dude get the [ __ ]
out of here man what are we gonna do
what are you gonna do
right we're in these [ __ ] goat carts
yeah you don't go that fast yeah this
beer is gonna look it's like a [ __ ]
buffet yeah and his brother black bears
oh okay
okay i feel better no let's listen they
run from you until they don't that's why
i was like no you we don't have anything
i have nothing i was like looking around
like i guess i'd take my helmet off and
whack them have you ever heard the
expression black fight back
brown lie down
white
good night
white now is that a racism nope is that
racist black bear fight back so if a
black bear attacks you it's predatory
it's trying to eat you it's hungry so
you fight your [ __ ] ass off you do
not crawl up in a boat right you have to
fight right if a grizzly bear attacks
you chances are it's a mama bear reflect
either or whatever she's protesting they
still play dead don't [ __ ] do
anything right now did you they don't
smoke caveat with that right yeah right
so that's what they say and the these
same experts go sharks don't like the
taste of humans oh really what shark
told you that how do you know their
taste buds
right bear yeah there's a beer yeah
now here's something with all
scout leader two years ago yeah your
family park stumbles upon a grizzly bear
in the cave uh-huh he in front of his
cub scouts goes fellas don't worry just
lay down
they go he's right he's a bear expert
that's what he's been told he's an eagle
scout he lays down do you know what
happened to that gentleman he got his
did he get eaten did he get his back did
he take a couple bites out of his back
and bud well he's saying those cub
scouts watch their cub leader get eaten
ass first yeah so so that's what happens
sometimes right so that you have to wear
steel britches
and you have to wear a metal back brace
yeah here's the thing run black white
brown yellow run run [ __ ] run okay
now hold on here's the thing jump in
your goddamn go-kart like i had yeah and
[ __ ] run i'm probably gonna push the
guy down which i thought about push the
guy down and save your son and yourself
well the thing is
with the grizzly bear there have people
been people that just play dead and they
get they get to get bit up a little bit
get bit up a little bit get their face
all ripped up and stuff um now if you
don't have bear spray you're going to
have a big problem but let's just say
you get beat up
polar bear 1700 pound male polar bear
100 percent you're going to be
100 what you said you do jump into no
matter what you well you can just say
you're pretty seven
say your prayers say your prayers say
your prayers
get find god quick get god quick you got
15 seconds dude find god hopefully he
accepts you so you get into the pearly
gates that's right he's going to bite
you on the back of the neck
shake yeah how nuts is that that that
instructor i'm like hold on do you have
a gun you have no you guys
let's get going buddy right that's why
that show i watch alone there's the
episode the the uh season frozen
they're on lab
labrador island there are polar bears
there
and that's where i got the expression
black fight back brown lie down white
good night and like who the [ __ ] how are
you putting people there with with polar
bears they will kill you they will eat
you right away especially if you're
alone i'm sure yeah
um so i go to andy stump's wedding our
boy annie stump's wedding in utah in
utah in kalispell he lives in kalispell
um where uh he's and and it was it was
[ __ ] yeah bring that up i'll show you
who was there by the way there's a rash
guards from toho uh don't be a little
cuck so that right there is that guy's
one of hicks and gracie's the oldest of
black belts the guy all the way henry uh
aikens you know henry akins right i know
henry yeah yeah great guy then there's
denver maddox who is um
uh he was a big tech guy and covered in
tattoos and he's andy's partner in black
rifle that's evan right there evan
heifer who is the ceo of black rifle
coffee love him by the way uh then
there's andy stumpf right there still
team six guy looks cool then there's
brian kellen the only guy not in total
flip-flops by the way andy is a big
toehold he's an owner now but he's also
a big touhou i like it i like the
variety yes owned 12 uh own 12 pairs of
toeholds and decided to have all his
people all his groomsmen in and you
didn't win
i had mine in my car and i put them on
after that because i didn't want to be
rude i don't want to go to the [ __ ]
wedding in
flip-flops but everybody got married in
them so you know with you
so and then that's going to give you the
memo nobody gave me the memo and that
guy right there is a guy named mike
glover who was in a in something called
delta of course
and he was you don't mess with those
boys no and then who's scared of the
tattoo on the hand he's the one i'm
worried about
uh oh that that's denver denver is
actually the least dangerous person in
that group well was that tattoo on this
actually what's he do denver is and he
does jiu jitsu but he's andy's partner
he's a big guy but you know who was
there also in the in the wedding was one
of his seal team six guys who looked
like
he came from the center of the sun
um he had he had been andy said he's the
most proficient seal he'd ever worked
with jesus he was a dev group guy you
know one of those guys i looked at him
in the lineup of the uh even in
flip-flops he looked dangerous like even
like i looked him in the lineup and it
was like mike lover badass and this guy
steve
who uh was a dev grew guy who's in still
team six for 11 years i assume everybody
yeah i mean yeah and you look at him and
i mean andy andy was like and he was
like that's the most proficient seal
i've ever worked with in my entire time
he goes
probably kill more people than kobet
oh
i mean yeah i was like i mean i don't i
don't wanna i don't wanna i'm not he was
joking yeah but that's basically yeah of
course he's a yeah but he's yeah uh but
but i was the first time i'd ever seen
anybody where i looked at him like mike
glover is a complete badass and has seen
all the action
but mike is like mike is like hanging
out with with just a great guy who seems
like just a really
well i don't know just all the way
around amazing guy and funny and and
silly and all that stuff but some of
those other guys are
no joke
this is this is this is him uh after
20 years
he he was when he was 18 years old he
was a guard the unknown soldier and he
had to do this and this is the first
time he's done it in 20 years he
remembers because i remembered it all he
goes i don't know his muscle memory
watch it
i love this [ __ ]
you're a little too into it huh
well mike right there is as tip of the
spear as you get you don't get
more elite as a soldier
he's half asian he's half korean oh yeah
you'll love this channel so wait you can
take this off
yeah he was he's half asian and his call
sign
evan gave him evan from black rifle
coffee gave well somebody gave him i
don't know seven but gave him a call
sign his call sign was gation
occasionally so you can't pick your call
so it's like so the guy who the guy who
said dude dude with the guy when he was
working with his others he was a
complete bad because i can't call you a
gay asian he goes sir
it's not gay
it's giant asian that's why he calls me
gayson but of course they called him
gays they just [ __ ] with each other all
the time those two that those those i
think the reason those operators love
each other so much they're all in
incredibly dangerous situations but when
you're with each other all the time all
you do is [ __ ] around anyway bro hey
real quick now did you get the boys
water
that i i'm a little too into it right i
got your cheerleader right well you
never see a cheerleader well well andy
said i'm sitting at the tactical table
because i know that you'll have a boner
the whole time correct yeah and then
you'll probably let them take turns on
your ass yeah and that's why i'm having
trouble sitting down and you're also
going to give them foot rubs right
that's why you came to the wedding foot
rob andy we figured it out my calls my
call sign if i was in there to their
unit my call sign would be too dangerous
or i'll be waiting back at camp no your
your name's your name's littlefoot my my
name would be brian littlefoot my name
is just a little footage his foot rubber
where's football he's back at camp
getting his getting lotion and i'd say
i'm stressed bring in the little foot
yeah um explode in his mouth
well i would have to do what i have to
do for my country
so so some american america if you're
american sometimes if you don't have the
bone structure to carry all that [ __ ] no
you're gonna earn your key and i'm not
that good at shooting and i'm not good
at all that like keeping my even though
they're retired you still gotta you know
they still got work to do are they
retired though and that's the question
you look at those guys you're always
like but wait you were just in it's like
tim it's like you were over there i know
yeah
but uh you had a good time though i had
a good time all [ __ ] aside with all
the silliness they're just fine and the
vacation was fine
the vacation well the vacation the bora
bora vacation we haven't talked about
bora bora
bora bora was was
and you and i have trouble on vacation
it's good for three days it's the one
place i think you could you could do a
week no
but i have my house how long's the
flight we're playing
eight hours what's good about bora bora
is this if it's a long flight i can stay
alone here's what you do you fly from 12
a.m
and you can land it at you it's an eight
hour flight so you sleep on the plane
it's a red eye right on planes i guess
it takes some money or something and
it's only a three hour difference you're
three hours behind that level that's not
bad yeah so you're you're acclimated
right away
the water is uh the water is blue warm
it's the greatest thing in the world
you see octopus and stingrays you swim
with sharks
if i didn't have my family there played
volleyball and tennis and pickleball
crazy
yeah but that's me yeah that's my i'm
good for three days yeah that's my place
but montana i i have to say i went
swimming in i went to this i went on a
hike
because we had uh sunday to kill and i i
gotten a moving stream a moving river
which i had never done or i hadn't done
it i don't know how long and that that
felt very good i just sat there in the
[ __ ] wild but i was i was with my
father-in-law we bring them with us and
we were sitting on the deck of the cabin
like staring at the just the mountains
all that stuff we're sitting there it's
our day two there
and he's like could you live out here i
went uh no no no no no no i said this is
good for like it gives me the break i
can shut down and get off my phone but
yeah after three days i go think about
doing this every day dude well like
especially for he was i could do it but
you're 60 something yeah like right i'm
just not there right now i have a theory
on it all i have a theory on texas
montana i have a theory on
uh and i'm kind of trying to write about
it but it's like i think that all of us
everybody
whether it's you know i don't care what
your background is we're all looking at
the future
and we're all wondering how we fit in
like our kids like
are we all gonna go like i'm not saying
this but there's this idea of like
are my skill sets and even my biology am
i going to go extinct like with ai with
drones with robots with all these things
that are coming it's hard to see a
future where human beings are not going
to be or at least the skills that we're
learning are not going to kind of be
somewhat obsolete there's this idea
right there's just so much is there i i
think a lot of people don't know
and i think that there's also another
idea which is
like
a lot of the guys that that that i see
out in texas there are two ways to deal
with if you're a white dude let's hear
white people are afraid at the end of
the day they're looking out there
they're going there's a big brown tide
coming and it's people of color and we
have to give up a piece of the pie and
where our place at the table is not
going to be as big as it was there's
that i don't care liberals tend to their
reaction is let's join the group yeah
it's about time [ __ ] all these white
people and then there are other people
that go i'm gonna fight i'm gonna i
gotta i gotta set my [ __ ] up for the
zombie apocalypse i'm not saying it's a
racist thing i see a lot of people
who
they go okay i'm gonna i'm gonna [ __ ]
i'm gonna own land have access to a well
and own all the guns and if i can't
afford that i'm just going to grow an
aggressive beard buy a truck and do jiu
jitsu i think you're hanging out with
too many special forces i don't know i
think there's a lot of times i don't
know anyone like that no i i rogan
well all of a lot of rogan's fan like
when you go to that show twelve thousand
people there's a lot of that there
there's all the ufc stuff i just think
that there's there's a lot of there's
there feels like there's
there's that um
there's that reaction it's a very
interesting reaction
we're so tribal that we're so tribal in
this country now that some tribes are
very woke that's that's one tribe the
other tribe is is the mma
tactical gear tribe trucks
it's almost like
it's almost like some men go
over here with as masculine as they can
get beards tattoos
guns
independence freedom other men
are actually going the opposite
direction i just can their dicks off
yeah there's a whole there's a it's a
really interesting thing but i feel like
maybe i'm wrong but i feel like we're
all breaking up into these very strong
tribes that we're a uniform i think it's
i think it's a little extreme i can get
how you can feel that way for sure yeah
especially if you're on social media
you're definitely going to feel that way
yeah social media breaks us into tribes
it does that's what's amazing [ __ ]
does
it really does and that's i think that's
without my wife that's new for all of us
including you in a way i'm not on social
media but you know what i mean though
like like like
social media has become a phenomenon
to the degree it is really interesting
six years it's tribes and you have your
your loyal fans and then you know are
following and then there's tribes us
versus them it's always that the debates
the beefs like that's all social media
the hate the toxic it's all social media
and do you know that um
90 of all tweets
are done by 10
of the people well twitter's irrelevant
it doesn't matter yeah no one's no no
young persons on twitter they they let
they laugh at twitter
i know my daughter says that youtube's
the biggest by far 100 tick tock and
youtube's the two biggest no yeah as far
as like younger millennials like
destroys everything i mean the
instagram's coming a little
i've decided tik tok is uh brain poison
i can't i have i told jimmy burke had to
go see somebody about it
because he's on tick tock i'm not
kidding
that's why it's built for it's built to
create addiction he couldn't get off it
my daughter can't get off it really the
chinese that's a chinese invention okay
they don't let their kids do it
because they know the back the the the
history yeah you know the stats yeah
they don't they but they they did like i
don't know man
i got a problem yeah not good
homeboy got kicked off what's his name
uh andrew andrew tate got kicked off
it's interesting because originally
because i get alerted to me when uh
before i went on the companion with bert
and have you seen the video that's going
around but i guess he was on big brother
in uk or something i didn't i don't know
his background so i guess he was on like
big brother celebrity show and it came
out there there's a video of him
you know whatever roughing up this girl
but apparently that's what she's into
yeah like i don't know the context yes
but if you don't know the context you
watch like jesus christ
but then i saw him explaining he's like
that's what she asked that's what she
wanted like people are constantly trying
to do this yeah anybody who takes
offense that just doesn't get chicks
well what do you do
it's a little rough it's a it's a little
rough but then it's like well yeah i
don't know the context with any of that
but then the alarming thing and again i
don't know the details and then also
because he's so outspoken because he is
a trump supporter you know people graft
those people right so then
now he's being investigated for uh sex
trafficking and that's a big one but
then i was talking about with mark it's
like
but it's like you see that headline six
traffic i'm like holy [ __ ] i'm off this
you know
uh tate fletcher train but then
entertain entertain training yeah
yeah i know fletcher's awesome uh andrew
t yeah i'm like oh that's not good you
know sex trafficking
but yeah i'm falling victim to the same
to happen with rogan same thing happened
to you know a lot of my friends where
it's like if you just read the headlines
don't look into it what's really going
on here because clearly the i don't buy
the
that video was it was exactly what that
was it's been out for years i didn't
know and that girl was into that that
was if you know the background that that
was a that was a consensual thing going
on
it's like the trevor bauer thing right
that that the picture for the dodgers if
you look at the the tweets if you i mean
if you look at the actual [ __ ] text
the text where she goes i've never been
more turned on in my life and she saw
him twice after that give me a [ __ ]
break dude
now you're so so what are you doing
dangerous rules right like knocking a
girl out punch her in the face i mean i
don't know yeah that's crazy i think he
got a little extra of course it did i
mean i'm not saying but i'm just saying
that what's what what's interesting is
that when
the when you you are in that and all of
a sudden
that no matter what you had with that
girl no matter how consensual that was
if that's what you guys are into that's
what you're into okay well it's kind of
like with uh army hammer hammer it's
like you you see the headlines are
cannibal jesus christ we never ate any
well no also but also they were engaged
like that's their game and now
when it gets out to the masses it looks
horrible yes but there's a lot of people
that that's their king of course and if
they both agreed to the rules then the
rules them the wrong they're not
breaking any laws
now if he kidnapped a girl and forced
her into that stuff she's a different
animal
but if you're both into it now it's
weird i'm not into that [ __ ] so i'm like
that's weird yeah but i don't think you
should be canceled well they are into it
and so was she and by the way the woman
that he was doing that with was a sex
worker
that was that that they had a long-term
thing going and then she got mad at him
apparently because he wasn't going to
marry her or something like that yeah
and then you know so so if you ever
would take you have to figure this [ __ ]
out it's like you know i see i got
kicked off and that's not good but then
i read like uh
you know and he he addressed it on some
show he was like i'm not mad i get why
they do it but he's like you know
they've been trying to do this forever
and he's like they act like you know sex
trafficking all this stuff he's like
they're really reaching here look and
you're like uh but he also he has an
agenda that's different than the left
who runs yeah social media platforms
yeah now you're getting too they're not
going to allow him to voice now you're
getting into it yeah he's getting too
big no they say he's a danger to young
men
that's what it is it's called censorship
and they'll use that they'll trump up
some idea around him to cancel him and
that's what they did you know i don't
believe it's going to make him bigger
though especially him
where he has his own platform dude
he sells his own like business like
being a man 101 or where the [ __ ] it is
like it's a subscription it's like alex
jones mark my words he'll he'll he'll
pay his 50 million
yeah and i think i think he'll probably
just
get bigger
i think in three years he's gonna be
bigger i don't know yeah maybe i don't i
think it's a little different because
alec jones i didn't agree with like no i
didn't think of shooting i was very
critical that's why i'm like what the
[ __ ] i was very critical of he's writing
on a lot of stuff
but then he has to come out and be like
oh it's a character it's an act you know
chris i don't believe all this so the
cat's out of the bag a little bit with
that that already came out how the
sausage is made yeah with tate he's like
i'm not apologizing for anything like
what so for him i think it makes him
bigger has he has he made a statement
yeah yeah he did a podcast i was gonna
read this because i remember i told you
i'd heard about this
heard about this human trafficking stuff
before
and i remember him telling a story about
it
it happened back in april
they came in and raided his house and
he was recalling like yeah they came in
and they're like hey sorry we have to do
because he's you know buddies with these
guys
no arrests were made no charges were
pressed this was four months ago and
every time i see it pop up now it's made
to seem like it just happened of course
it would of course you know or he's been
arrested but that's what the press does
months ago and it's no charge i don't i
don't follow him you know so again when
i saw it when at first i think david
lucas said he's like look at this [ __ ]
he's [ __ ] yeah and i just see that and
then we go live in the campaign i'm like
dude what the [ __ ] and we read that
girl's uh instagram yeah well i don't i
don't know she's a comic yeah and i'm
reading it and it's like sex trafficking
yeah well they're just not gonna
investigate sex trafficking over
internet rumors you're dealing with the
feds here man this is not good yeah but
then you look like a remote yeah and
then you're looking at more like oh that
was months ago and they've been trying
to do this still
yeah and then i'm like oh he's part he
got too big
yeah it just reminds me of this friend
who's very famous not joe rogan big
communion who got offered these huge
roles and um and yeah he and i thought
he was going to do it and then i go the
f what are you doing he goes no way dude
because i say too much wild [ __ ]
you don't want to get to that level
because you want to be just on the couch
but this is what yours cause you go that
way then they come because they can use
they can use anything as a weapon and
they do
and then and then hollywood you know
they're just like nope we're out and
well corporations do the problem is that
that if corporations and hollywood
believed in due process if they actually
believed in looking at evidence and not
that [ __ ] but once the press says
something you're [ __ ] right here's the
question b
how do guys like uh tate and army hammer
and then fight back you can't
well how do you find an answer
how so so how do you i do not want that
answer yeah i'll tell you how you fight
back you have to create your own
platform good luck with that i mean ever
can't do that army hammer can't take him
he's already donating
but there are other people like like
what happens is
that no crime no jones did too no crime
nothing that you could prosecute nothing
with our army hammer let's take him as
an example nothing nothing there that he
had a kink
he and this girl had this kinky [ __ ]
going on and they've been going on way
[ __ ] before that and it was it was
back and forth okay way before that
and so now
she gets mad
and she for whatever reason has a
grievance and now some if somebody in
the press picks it up
he's beauty he's tall he comes from a
very wealthy family and all that [ __ ]
he's done dude he's done you have people
in the new york post going he should
never be because he's only in hollywood
like but also he should be so what's so
so good so he's only in hollywood so for
that i guess take out take out army
hammer because
if you're in hollywood you're playing
that game and hollywood's ran by local
liberals there's nothing you're not
going to get in the club
liberals they're hypocrites because none
of them
are coming they're all they're all
they're all make a fortune but they side
with them because it's just business
yeah for now for now for now
but if you're if you're taking these
other guys there has to be some like how
far until we go enough's enough
because the number one problem is these
major social media outlets twitter
facebook instagram all this [ __ ] take
not take talk but those three main ones
that the americans use
they're all ran by
woke liberals so if they don't agree
with your political beliefs or they
think you're sending a message which
doesn't align with theirs they're going
to find a way to kick you off that's how
they find the way they call they call
their friends in the press who are
exactly like them and that's what they
do they're not even journalists there
has to be something like that well
the first move that was going to help
some of this was if elon musk bought
twitter yeah which isn't gonna you know
it doesn't look like it's happened but
if you had a person who's not that way
would would help and then i think you'd
make twitter more popular look the only
way you can fight back is
look at johnny depp with all his money
at for six years he got he was done
off of an article and that doesn't work
he had the money to sue yeah you're
talking about but he also said a million
dollars b
right that's what it takes exactly
you can't it's not realistic and also in
california you basically somebody can
say anything to you you can't sue them
because it's called it's called a slap
motion they're allowed to tell their
story
so some people say well you should sue
and stuff like that good luck with that
because it'll get thrown out of course
well you also go broke though but even
if you win you're all right you won
you're broke so what are you going to do
so suing is not the answer because
you're not johnny depp
it's interesting like back to the media
like obviously they get on board and
completely [ __ ] paint the narrative
yeah you have you watched that doc man
tie tail unknown he was a notre dame
foreign
dude i've been uh texting with him dude
you know what it breaks your [ __ ]
heart because right you know the whole
catfish thing i don't go over it but he
had a girlfriend had a fake girlfriend
trans guy well well not the time it was
just a dude and then now is trans in the
in the the
documentary that's whatever eight years
ten years pass
he was the first case that we know of
really is catfish right they're like a
popular one so he you forget how good he
was at football
i mean dude he's supposed to be a top 10
pick in the nfl went to the national
championship because of him stud out of
high school
had 20 offers ufc ucla goes notre dame
musician linebacker a hawaiian kid
monster very religious
part of the problem is one of the
reasons why he fell into this trap is
because he's so naive he's very
religious
you know as a religious guy he's not
having sex before marriage right so he
to him having a uh just a dm
relationship was normal this was a good
person he sees the pictures he called
his buddy who also talked to her and he
confirmed it's her so he's like there's
nothing wrong here and he's so busy with
football he's not worried about hooking
up with this jake he has a relationship
somebody can vent to he's too busy yeah
but the public can't they can't like
hold on three years you can see this
girl you know he's in on it and he's
like no no what i had nothing to do it
so then national championship it gets
released that
grandma did die but there's no evidence
that this girl existed he's made it all
up so he he gets a crisis management
team
and they go what should we do they go do
nothing don't do anything yet don't
worry don't do anything we'll figure it
out don't do anything
so they asked him i think it was right
before the national championship you
know how do you feel about your
girlfriend dying and he knew at that
time that she was that was all fake but
he was like
what do i do so he's just like oh yeah
you know i think about her every day but
and that's it
whatever lose get blown out in that
championship to i think alabama good
alabama team then it comes out but why
does it come out dead spin
dead spin these two journalists who were
in the documentary
they start figuring it out and they have
some like guy who used to work for
anonymous so he can check backgrounds
and stories and he's like it's crazy
nobody called stanford she said she went
to stanford nobody called sanford as for
records nothing and he they scour their
internet she doesn't exist they find the
real girl she's like yeah that's me
she's like from california she's like
what what the [ __ ] someone's using my
identity so they go they try calling
manti teow and his family and all the
people involved and no one's getting
back to him because like we don't want
to touch this so manti tell tells his
agent like dude what should i do there
do nothing
dead spin goes
we have to get in front of the story we
don't want somebody else telling the
story we weren't gonna fact check
everything we're gonna look into it so
they come out and paint it like he was
involved in it when i say it ruined this
young man you remember that time he's 21
29 when i say ruined him dude the media
instead of fact checked and getting his
story jump right i needed the story out
before because they wanted likes and
clicks of course so they of course and i
see ruined his life i believe well what
happens with that well what happens with
that is memes start to become a thing so
he's a meme now
and he and he it breaks your heart
because when he's talking i was choking
up he goes people just made fun of me he
was people just made fun of me non-stop
he was people i would see me on the
streets and go holy [ __ ] i'm a biggest
fan take pictures with me then i'll get
on his social media and see him making
fun of me
would never do to my face then they on
instagram they're making fun of me
because i get drafted by the chargers
because of this whole instance the nfl
teams were like that's too dicey you're
supposed to get draft in the top 10 in
the first round that's his dream he goes
second round whatever 38th pick to san
diego chargers
cool it's your dream get dressed by the
chargers
that's the [ __ ] san diego union of
the newspaper he gets drafted you know
what's on the front cover when he gets
there it's a it's a cartoon of walking
on a beach with a with just his arm over
nobody there going babe you're going to
love san diego he goes that was my
welcoming when i get san diego so he
goes
the football field used to be my
sanctuary he's like if you didn't know
who manti tao is i guarantee you're
going to find out that's where i
flourish i have more confidence than
anywhere in the world when this stuff
came out people started making fun of me
and i would walk in a room and everyone
stopped talking it was it took all that
from me and i got the nfl and i was a
shell of myself that's right so he
laughed he was kind of you would you
know he could have been all pro that's
right confidence gone ruins his career
and even now people are still making fun
of him he's married two kids gorgeous
wife does he still play football no no
no he's free agent now
brewing them ruining them because he
goes i was always second guessing myself
down and then i felt you can't do that
and and and and and let me tell you and
here's what doesn't matter if you're
innocent let me tell you something when
people when enough people have that view
of you when somebody paints you as a
monster or as somebody well that you're
one over like you're lying you don't you
don't life doesn't prepare you for that
[ __ ] i can speak from experience but
with the crisis team it's like man if
you guys would just told him all those
cameras waiting for you up front he
would run past them not tell a story no
tell your story dude all right if you
would have gotten from crisis management
here's what happened i had catfish had
no [ __ ] clue
i have nothing to do with this it's
heartbreaking i'm embarrassed i have
nothing to do with this
boom
but deadspin goes nope we need likes and
clicks so whatever maybe make some money
off that article sure and you get credit
as the ones to break the news
you've ruined this human being's
livelihood you [ __ ] pieces of [ __ ]
that's right you've ruined him that's
right this delicate human being they
don't care
they don't know they're laughing about
it you're not even they're not a human
being on the documentary they're
laughing about it these this this fat
small
pale kids laughing and you've ruined
this [ __ ] you guys i said dead spin
over what they knew they were wrong and
they still did it oh they went we
weren't going to wait to see if the
story was true or fact-checked so they
come out uh manti tail in on it hoax
there you go and and but that gets
blasted everywhere you sue them for that
i don't know i don't know i should i
should ask him great guys because
because you're gonna crack down the
documentary because he goes
you get emotional seeing it because he
goes people are so mean to me they still
are he was like i'm a mean man they make
fun of me non-stop and he goes but it's
my duty because there are kids out there
who come up to me go oh you're my
favorite or whatever and he's like
so now it's my obligation not to put
that on them i say thank you so much
and i give back to them because i'm not
going to let these haters let me tell
you something let me tell you something
the biggest [ __ ] challenge
that you face when something like that
happens to you the biggest [ __ ]
challenge that you face
is not letting it take your light not
letting it take turn you into a shell
that's why fighting back and speaking up
is so important so his management team
doesn't know what the [ __ ] they were
talking about well these are but he was
a young expert he's a college kid you
look at me again they're getting paid
i'll tell you how much they get paid 20
grand a [ __ ] month oh at least [ __ ]
that yeah no dude they don't know what
they're talking about but you watch the
he's a baby brother listen he's a baby
listen listen man listen
you you we are living in a time
and dave portland talks about it and
this is a good example where
it is trial by media
you they are judge jury and executioner
they will ruin your life they will write
an article it will never go away and it
will color your life for the rest of
everything and your job when you face
that kind of [ __ ] chaos is to
you you go back to who you really are
you believe in yourself you don't stop
you keep going until you [ __ ] die you
you but most people
if you're sensitive and we're all
sensitive all you want to do is run away
and quit you want to curl up in a ball
and die
especially in things like that and your
job is to figure out a way to get that
light back and not let them take that
[ __ ] light from you you keep writing
yeah that's what you keep moving where
it's keep working he's like they're not
going to get to me because i keep giving
back to kids and you know he has two
kids now beautiful wife [ __ ] that piece
wife yeah but here's the other thing the
problem with the media is
where was the story that he wasn't
involved with the media
loves destruction but where's that at
because human beings like watching
destruction they like a train wreck they
don't like watching okay so i'm gonna
tell you hey brandon you gotta watch
that train just keep going on smooth
tracks for a long time it's like
watching paint dry if i say you want to
watch a train crash into a [ __ ] wall
and explode i'm watching i'm watching we
love seeing the structure i posted that
i said two tiggers media sucks and two
be [ __ ] nice to each other man
because that could happen to any of you
guys it can happen and when you live in
a world i always say it could happen to
the despondent when you live in a world
without due process you're [ __ ] next
you're next
that's that's the way it is you got to
watch that being it dude it will it will
break your heart man i believe it break
heart yeah i mean him started
communicating wow i had to reach out to
him like ah dude i am so sorry that
happened get him on the podcast i said i
can't yeah i should get him on the
pocket yeah
i'd love to talk to you because i wish
they because they also didn't follow up
no follow-up following up would ruin the
story it's not about following up it's
about clicks because that's that's not a
human being but that's the first time
that he's come out and really talked
about and they have his cap on there
who's transgender not a human being it's
a target
but not anymore but not anymore like if
you're into a documentary do it right
and the you know they're good and
they're on manti teo's side but it's
also like
well give us an update what he's doing
now mention that he's married to a
[ __ ] ten i don't mean a nine or an
eight i mean a ten after all this
[ __ ] bring up that he's a great
father bring up that he has a baby girl
and a son on the way bring up that he's
okay bring up he didn't quit bring up he
gives back bring up he's a [ __ ] dime
piece himself now yeah he's a beautiful
[ __ ] human yeah stop bringing bring
some of that [ __ ] up
yeah he's a stud you have a problem with
that
hey dead spin how's your wife look but
that's the problem with those those pain
it comes down to jealousy dude it comes
down to jealousy you can't destroy
somebody physically so you have to do it
behind and then show his kids hey dad
spin do your kids look like that
[ __ ] gerber baby models you [ __ ]
soy boys
he still wins
because he outworks you
in every facet of life yeah
i never heard of dead spin anyway
it sucks man but you know you go through
that [ __ ] and you actually took a
netflix doc to tell us [ __ ] story
destroy you or make you better ten years
later yeah let it disappear to your mind
but that's when you're in the desert
you're in the desert for a long time and
then they do a show like that and you
come out and i think that'll help him oh
my god yeah if you watch that and you're
still like i think you're in on it
you're a [ __ ] you're a [ __ ]
look at johnny depp
crushing it now
yeah a little different but with him he
had nothing to do with it dude he's like
he was a call he was a victim college
kid
yeah remember when you're in college
dude imagine that pressure what they'll
tell you now imagine you're a top five
talent in the world and because you fell
for this stupid elaborate catfish scheme
you lose your stock in the draft did
they interview you did they interview
catfish oh
catfish uh transgender yeah that's the
other bumper
if you're gonna get catfished
yeah
bro i saw i saw in the in this warlock
this hawaiian warlock catfish in the
trailer i saw that that that if you're
going to be transgender that's
it's it's a tough it's a tough foot
it's tough look what being simone being
transgender why it's tough why yeah not
a good look you're welcome did you have
those legs
right now hold on let's be nice but what
what is no [ __ ] be nice what is that
person she ruined his [ __ ] life what
did that person's right there go go that
one where he's in the the white jersey
number five it'll show the picture of
him
and then what he looks like now
uh-huh
uh-huh now he's a kid
now what did uh what did the catfisher
say is he very sorry yeah okay and uh
manti dow uh he said he had a
breakthrough because
i think he's talking to a therapist or
someone and they go uh you gotta forgive
and it was i forgave whatever the
transgender person goes i forgave her a
long time ago man i don't have any
resentment he goes no no you forgive
yourself
and he said that was like a breakthrough
for him and the guy was like yeah
forgive yourself because
you're so hard on yourself for falling
for this and going down this road you
blame yourself it's hard not to dude
it's it's really it's really easy for me
to hate myself it's been always hard to
like myself that's why i'm a comic i
think well yeah you think i like
you know
i'm just kidding yeah mark's been the
problem
mark was the problem in day one
i i leave highly
mean comments on mark's pro [ __ ] his
[ __ ] body perfect hair man that's
true you don't get like that
if you're somebody if you're somebody
that's always working hard to get better
it's because you don't like yourself so
then when that [ __ ] happens it's hard no
if you like yourself you're gonna stop
talking about it if you content no that
do i'm telling you that doc a it's
amazing b it's so heartbreaking and if
see if you watch that and you're still
mean to people on the internet
dude
you suck
it you watch it like ah [ __ ] this kid
man
he was a kid there most people that are
not living the life they should become
resentful and they hate existence and
they certainly just some people just
hate success they hate excellence they
hate anybody trying to be better yeah
it's their own insecurities it's just
what it is rogan was talking about that
on he was like they should all take
mushrooms it would make them nicer do
you know that they've had some really
interesting things with psilocybin where
if you push mushrooms on me one more
time
i'm going to i'm going to stuff
mushrooms through your [ __ ] they've
done some really interesting studies on
partner department of violence like men
who hit women and stuff and when they
take one dose of psilocybin they're like
far less likely to become violent
interesting it's got such powerful you
give them mushrooms literally oh that's
gonna go over well sir relax just eat
this take this
this this plant while the guy's in the
height of his [ __ ] anger yeah she
cheated on me i get it i get it bubba
just take this take this
if there's more science and knowledge on
it they'd probably take it right but so
taboo yeah well i mean i wouldn't take a
weird-looking mushroom from a cop rogan
said that when he was going through all
his [ __ ] when they were trying to cancel
him he would take a gram of day he was
just happy he's like i'm just happy [ __ ]
it
interesting yeah because i feel like you
could take and then go down a weird
route no people think that no i'm just
saying
i'm i'm a rookie in this game well i
went to hell you we know well i went to
hell because i got caught in an infinite
loop
and everybody around me turned into you
can't even give all the details
i'm talking about your your
mushroom journey and well it is it's
like it's my search for god you know
i've been reading and doing all this
stuff and i went down the rabbit hole
now six grams i dissolved into the sun
ended up in the fetal position and
apparently was saying some things that
were
outrageous is that a good way to say i'd
say outrageous and then tell me i
couldn't stop farting too i was
i was
i was
he was
i was farting an elephant yeah i was
just i was just non-stop
and that i would come into consciousness
i would look up and i would see like
somebody and i would just i knew i was
in a room and i was just like
and i would fart and i knew i was being
it was outrageous but i couldn't murder
but then i fell free i was blind though
you know what i love i was blind i love
that those people i'm sure you're not
the first one just take shrooms and fart
all day for eight hours so i bet they're
like just let it go brian just don't
hold it in yeah just
oh there it is there it is there it is
come on apparently they were very nice
to me and they were trying to take care
of me and
you know you're [ __ ] better i i was
gone you gotta get a bit out of that i
will i will because i was i'm gonna i'm
gonna it's the funniest story ever i'm
actually gonna if you could have told
the story on the podcast dude i already
called jim you won't believe what
happened you were laughing so hard oh my
god dude i didn't know it's
i was told by my friend and then i
talked to the shaman guy and he said
yeah
yeah and he said and he tried to make me
feel better he goes look the first time
i took that many grams i took all my
clothes off went into the other room and
told told everybody that i was going to
lay them out if they came in there
hilarious so i was like well okay i'm
not alone but i mean his story's been
yours a little better than mine i could
have yeah that was bad
but it was the whole thing was a
disaster
but i don't remember it i when people
when i tell you yeah when i tell you
that i went blind and i don't remember
anything i'm telling you that i came
in and out when i would fart and i would
just hear the room go um like that yeah
we're not talking a little fart we're
talking brian
yeah someone was like oh who let the
wild boar i remember feeling it i
remember my ass felt like uh you're like
you're doing [ __ ] all over dude i kept
thinking i was [ __ ] diarrhea well i
kept saying i told you the first when i
did mushrooms at first all i was trying
to do was i was like i was trying not to
[ __ ] my pants i was like i i i can't
[ __ ] my pants in this hole i think i
need like a bowl of chili yeah like if i
had done that and just sprayed the walls
brown yeah and i come too i'm like hol
it smells like [ __ ] in here yes yeah
dude yeah you [ __ ] all over the world so
so i heard my buddy said uh he was in a
group and they were doing ayahuasca and
there was a woman
and she was
there's this this is this is this group
and this woman was sitting there she
goes i think i shat my pants but i'm not
sure but i think i did i think i shat my
pants although i don't know and she just
kept saying that and she was just
sitting like did she
nobody checked and then another guy came
up and he goes apparently he walked up
to my friend and said hey i have
something to tell you and he goes what
he goes
and they're all tripping balls and he
goes i'm afraid i'm lucifer
and they go oh
okay well that's not good he goes i know
and he told that to people also tripping
yeah i'd have to kill him i know i
wonder what how's that go down in court
of law
i
real quick told me he was the devil yeah
then i saw horns a pair
if i killed everybody if i kill
everybody you can't hold me accountable
you can't
because i did right speaking of shoes
don't remember anything uh first time
i'm doing comedy store in hot second sam
tripley show
yeah backstage jeff dye theo me
uh eliza monsters wow sitting back there
how's eliza doing great because you know
she had a baby i didn't know yeah
killer crushes anyways uh tony rock
absolutely destroyed most unread comic
in the [ __ ] play yeah it's so [ __ ]
good amazing anyway
joshua i'm sitting back there i'm
watching theo said he's so [ __ ] funny
his new stuff so good and joshua can i
talk to you real quick you know me and
josh are close uh what's up man is dude
i [ __ ] up i took some shrooms i
shouldn't have because i am so [ __ ] up
right now wait josh josh wolfe oh jeff
and i go really and i go josh josh
and you can hear me coherently yeah i go
good thing you've been in comedy for 40
years and you figure it out up there
buddy don't be nervous and he goes
here's the other thing i [ __ ] my pants
off
oh yeah well yeah and then and then i
swear and then it's like well theo's
like that's my time he's supposed to be
like 15. i did like 11 and josh was
after him he's like i gotta go on stage
i'm like with poopy butt
he went up there swap out and dig well
did his thing look no no not swamp ass
no no he shot
mud the dose makes the poison don't
don't do enough to [ __ ] your pants if
you're gonna do mushrooms
do a gram two grams don't do enough to
shake your pants it was so funny though
sense of urgency he was all which
hey josh good thing you didn't caught me
so long it doesn't matter wow yeah but i
also [ __ ] my pants i couldn't just i
went well that's a problem i couldn't
stand up on mushrooms well that's a
problem and they go josh you're up and
he's like i'll see you out there yeah no
no
you give me three grams it's not a shot
i could do that ah dude i shot i told
you one time i was a tripoli rogan i
forget who else
and roman's like come on dude take your
eddie you're in the back green room at
the community
you know i'm not a weak guy i'm the
first thing i've never been a wee guy i
mean i just don't do well on it i get
anxiety i eat everything in the house i
put on weight it's not for me yeah i'm
like ah rogan's doing it i won't be like
him give it to me till your puff bro
i've never in seven years doing comment
i've never forgotten a tag any
nothing came out dude and adam you get
the guy who passes you in the back like
this watching me
i'm like
rogan i'm talking 12 000 people rose
high 12 000 people and he's really
professional he's but but weed for him
makes him
clear
literally i think rogan's in six girls
we brings down to two second gear i'm
i'm never inside i don't know man i
don't need to be in sixth gear i'm
always in two if i'm if i'm really
moving i'm third gear never i never get
this i don't see i don't see weed affect
his intensity or focus even a little bit
i think it yeah i think it actually
increases his intensity and focus i
think for some people if it works for
you doing it yeah it's a chemical thing
if it works
weed provides a bomb yeah he's he's he
smoked weed and became a multi
multi-millionaire
yeah which would happen and he'll be a
billionaire in time
i'm sure i mean who knows he's
with you well i mean if you want to feel
bad about yourself i mean i'm very proud
of my friend but you go from wise guys
to seeing your friend play twelve
thousand people here i don't compare
yourself but wow don't do that no no
don't do that don't compare it don't do
that not derozan
well it's like yeah me and bert were
talking about this like bert was like
you're one of the few guys who are like
me where i i look at things i celebrate
everything i see the best and everything
like me too i go burton not that you've
ever made a bad special i said your
special could be the worst i've ever
seen i'm gonna get on this mic and say
it's the best i've ever seen i say
because you're my friend and that's how
i roll i said also
i view it different like certain parts i
can find that were [ __ ] brilliant man
and that's what i'm going to highlight
he's like that's he goes where's the
exact see he's like that's why i mean
you were close man and bert's always
been so supportive he's the busiest guy
in the [ __ ] world when i say he's
crushing it
dude
you don't know but i mean rogan's
crushing it right dude
birdie boy
bro him and segura bro oh
here's a so rogan right if if our if we
have a team rogan's up here right he's
the owner of the team and then
tom's right behind him tom does arenas
you know i have thick boy stews tom's my
north star tom has you know your mom's
house studios
you know selling arenas like toms
tom does what i'm the i'm the alicab
version of tom you know i'm in clubs and
you know doing the
the camera here this time in hd you know
it's i'm trying man you know but you
know so thomas i don't think people
realize how big tom is like metronome
doesn't know comedy material first time
i've ever seen him nervous
he was such a fan of bird i didn't know
that he goes dude [ __ ] i can't believe
you got bert cresco bert he's yeah oh i
go that's my guy man he was really like
oh dude he's that's like my [ __ ] guy
he's like oh my god do i oh you're
nervous you don't know bert they hit it
off like a [ __ ] it's great
because they're both into
grateful dead and all that [ __ ] and i
was just letting them talk and making
fun of them that's so good yeah i'm glad
sam was there too oh sam's a kill killer
killer he's so conspiracy social club on
rockfin you know you know sam does seven
podcasts i i i keep saying well he kept
promoting him on the show tell him can
you tell him to do just conspiracy
social club and one other i mean
come from me i know but [ __ ]
stop doing seven podcasts dude he kept
promoting and i thought it was a bit
here we go we have this show and in my
hand like he's doing bad i'm not gonna
ruin this no and they did another one he
starts trying to go wait what's the show
about and i go oh
you actually do that podcast yeah i do
seven podcasts ago oh you're being
serious because yeah what do you do more
than me
he's so funny dude so you know we did a
four-hour podcast with bert for bare
knuckles it's a long day we have about
three hours off to go home clean the
house before family came home because i
made a mess i'm a [ __ ] gila monster
at home so my undies were like on the
kitchen counter so i had to clean up
i get no rest and i'm like [ __ ] dude i
do have another [ __ ] you know those
companions a lot i'm like alright here
we go i'll have some drinks whatever
so i get there and then i'm like oh yeah
sam tripoli's on the show and i just
happened he does a lot of work and i
happen to be balls deep in the jfk
junior conspiracy
that i got all and then i just started
put in my back pocket if i run out of
things
i go dude hey alt this is all i took
dead air boring fight
hey sam how about jfk man believe in one
shooter
boom he's amazing 40 minutes of content
and hilarious the best he is he knows
way more about it every time he walks in
the room when we're doing a conspiracy
social club that [ __ ] walks in
the room and i just go
i i can just sit back and because i've
never we've done
169 episodes now
i've never seen him babies i've never
seen him off he's never been off well if
he would i want to just him have him
focus on
just that and we would [ __ ] i mean
he's just so good he's so [ __ ] how
frustrating is it when and you know i
like it's
you'll you'll understand especially now
so you want sam to focus on conspiracy
right isn't it frustrating when he won't
he's doing all this other stuff i
remember when we started fighting the
kid yeah i kept telling you dude please
focus on playing the game doing 15 tv tv
[ __ ] missing the show and i was like
doing it with random people oh my god i
remember so well um i started my own
podcast brian county oh did you good
brother i did my first uh episode um i'm
going to release it soon where do you do
it at i do it in my studio where i do
comparison social club but i have my own
setup now
so i have room here
i would love the only thing is it's such
a drive for me it's such a fun i'm sure
if you need if you need a setup like
because yeah no chappelle's gone we have
room yeah yeah you can make your own set
whatever you want to do great yeah i
don't need anything use the camera use
the guys i love you for that yeah if you
need it um isn't it what
yeah it feels good to just do my own
i've got some ideas it's a skill set
it's a skill set mm-hmm
and uh how about martin and this is
kudos to mark you know mark's never done
podcasting before and i go hey dude i'm
starting to network and i want you you
know he's so entertaining i want you to
do your own podcast here's oh you know
everyone's like who's he can do it with
him like you knew by yourself now
as podcasters we've done we have our 10
000 hours we have our black belts and
podcasting
mark's never done podcasting my dumb ass
but and this is the trust i have in mark
are you you're gonna do it by yourself
it's mission impossible there's about 10
of us who can do it by themselves you
rant through a phone you have a bit of a
narcissist you ran in into the [ __ ]
camera there's no audience you're not
bouncing ideas you've got i'm telling
you but you can do it [ __ ] mark never
done putt what episode
what episode
uh 40 something 40 something he's very
talented by himself did you see his
commercial for oak and bold he did
i was like
you need to get
stoned right
oh daddy he does get a percentage who do
you think he is
he's very good
i did the deal thank you
he's very good yeah yeah very [ __ ]
he's never done just instrumental in
putting that deal together i love it um
i really appreciate that that's really
sweet and um you know obviously goes
without saying i'm very grateful for
you're an actor for everything you're an
artist thank you you're the bodybuilding
is your your way of expressing yourself
and i appreciate you saying that because
you've told me that before and it's like
i try not to make other people define me
that way but it's really nice to hear
from other people no you're you're a
sensitive guy but i i think with mark
because he looks like then he's jack and
stuff like that i think people will
assume like meathead no
way more sensitive than you and i
he's way more i wouldn't say that
more top tense people i know yeah very
smart yeah and creative smart as [ __ ]
would you would you would uh
you know
real quick this is a pedigree just to
build up market you know his brother
went to john hopkins ever heard of it
wow he went to harvey mudd underground
and then he had he get his phd and
applied math and computer science uh
johns hopkins so really
yeah yeah all of him and hell
harvard lawyer and stuff like that so
their kids are going to be my other
brother is very smart too it says he was
more he was actually like the athlete of
the family you know he was a higher
level wrestler better football player
than me but was he the one who came
tough about her yes it doesn't look like
it now but he's actually he's fine
also more popular than me right so he's
like an injured wall once he got to
college and you know he's a party animal
like so we were like dude your brother's
so fun i'm like i know andy's like shy
andy so he gets drunk he can dance like
that was his gimmick because like the
300-pound guy who can just dance off and
oh nothing like everybody loves big fat
white guy
you know heart is a dancer such as yes
it's sort of shocking how good he is
well that's like bert i was asking him
because he brought up uh you know he was
labeled the biggest party animal in
america from florida state and florida
state was the number one party school at
the time it's cu every year now not a
big deal shout out to cu alum but he uh
he was on the rolling stones biggest
part of animal and i go hold on bert i
bet you got chicks dude and he goes no
no never no no
he goes i could never figure it out he
was i was the fun party guy i could
never close the deal because everyone
views me as the buddy it was also i'm
not driven by hooking up with chicks i'm
driving with people liking me and having
fun he goes so i never
pursued it and they never came at me i
was like what you're in rolling stones
in the [ __ ] 90s and you weren't
getting your dick sucked doing backflips
he was new he was only had six or six
women he's amazing yeah he just wasn't
my thing he's still today it's not it's
not i'm not motivated by sex and all
that
i'm like wow god bless him yeah
god bless burt crusher oh the best i'm
sorry i missed that fight companion that
would have been fun oh it's been so
funny
we'll do it next we'll do it dude i'm
telling you four hours go by
i thought it was an hour i know that's
how good bird is i know
you had bert and sam tripoli on that bad
boy and matrion's no slouch either
mitchell's [ __ ] machone's the best
dude dude metron i go hey dude
i'm doing a companion at 11 a.m you down
he's like dude it's my son's first
football game
nobody knows being a dead one of me
don't worry about it he was hold on let
me figure out let me see what time the
game is goes his son's game leaves at
half time to make the flight to come
here he's a great the beast that great
dad yeah so he makes the fight here and
then uh but two days before that i go
have a wild idea he was what i go what
do you think about doing the podcast
with bert at 11 and then saturday night
there's big ufc
my family's not even here i'm free dude
you down to a second companion he goes
why not let's get wild
so good he got hammered on the bird yeah
even burt just hit it off there yeah
dude
how do you not hit it off with matt
matrion he's the best he's [ __ ] the
best i love that guy
i love him all right jim what do you got
all right uh the first one is
we waited for you to do this this guy
that gets 100 erections a day yeah
that's a curse
well so apparently he never had this
before that was me in middle school
i couldn't stand that uh no you i'd
always tuck it up into my sweats
all the way up to my 20s dude no in
middle school is it disaster like you're
going to [ __ ] get your lunch i know
you're saying you tuck it into your belt
yeah yeah i've done that yeah it works
like the submarine thing
but he said he never had this issue
before it's just when he met this girl
and he went to check it up at the
hospital too
but they said there's nothing wrong with
him it's just he just found this woman
that he just finds super attractive i
don't buy it so they could just talk
hang out and he'll just get an erection
yeah well he's stupid and also i don't
buy this guy he looks like you have that
big old stupid dick he looks like he
looks like leon edwards uh [ __ ]
less athletic brother um some sort of
relationship she's scrolling down but
see look at her picture here does she
have a big ass look at her here
she's doing some some filter stuff for
sure
i mean like look at this completely
different oh that's a filter there yeah
god bless
she's older she's an older there might
be something
uh every uh let's see through the whole
relationship he's always had an erection
shops restaurants the gym how can you
work out with a boner you just want uh i
just wonder if any other couples are the
same sometimes it's embarrassing
it's like all right hold on the devoted
girlfriend says martin's constant desire
for sex cuts into her own time she
struggles to keep up with the chores
appointments
while meeting his naughty i bet he just
needs it all the time he can go to sleep
with an erection wake up with one even
though he does night shifts there's no
change that at all
it's every single place we are we have a
we we can be having a perfectly normal
everyday conversation should we climb
mountains next weekend he has an
erection and come down the stairs and
walk past the glass door and be in the
next room it still happens dude yeah
that's a curse
because you have an erection for too
long it hurts so brian right now
that'd be a nightmare you're in middle
school and you really don't know how to
deal with it
yeah
when was the last time you had a real
stiffy this morning
you had some sex this morning no
you just had a [ __ ] heart the kids
come in the room there's no morning sex
oh yeah my son boston wakes up goes pop
let's go downstairs it's five in the
morning dude but then i you know i wear
whitey tighties right there i can't wear
anything else they're colored though
because [ __ ] stains right smart yeah
sure make sure they're so i have dark
colored undies yeah i get up and big
dick just hanging out man my girl goes
get look at your dick i'm like i didn't
see that [ __ ] dragon tail down there
yeah
big old angry so i told him like whoops
he woke up a little early i went good
morning good morning little tan hut
you're welcome
a little tent hut oh he's angry they say
it's healthy if you wake up with a boner
well i need a little feed that's that
bad boy needed to get his face in the
feed bucket yeah
you need to wake up
like if you're not getting blood flow to
the penis
it could be something else would you say
mike just like cardiovascular issues
you know viagra was a heart medication
you know like to open up your campaigns
but that's so it is this sign of health
that's pretty important blood pressure
um you know and they say it's healthy
like if you get boners in the morning it
means your testosterone is good yeah yes
yeah i mean it's not everyone but pretty
frequently everyone here get in the
morning the morning i still do yeah but
i can't do anything i get my kid i mean
i don't want to scare the [ __ ] kids
away you know big old
dog angry dick in the morning and his
morning breath
so this woman was charged with murder
because uh she went to visit her i guess
her
boyfriend in jail and she
distributed meth in a balloon with her
mouth when she kissed him it popped no
so i don't know if it popped in his in
his stomach he died right so this is a
guy
this guy that died that's the guy died
and this is the girl that did it oh she
looks like she would deliver meth but so
i don't know if he did the meth
afterwards and then he died or if it
popped in his stomach and then he died
yeah but she's charging
yeah yeah he could have wow yeah because
if he took it and hasn't had it in a
while some real good [ __ ] and then he
overdosed that's on her yeah yeah
i was reading the other day you probably
don't have it here i should have sent it
but you know whitey bulger's family
suing the state for 200 million dollars
because they're saying it makes no the
the prison that he went to is
the violent felon oh dude they call i
forget the name a horrible prison like
known for violence yeah and they put him
in with a kid who has ties to him who
wants to kill him well no they put him
in with the guy stephen got charged
they put him with a guy who didn't turn
and he's doing it like
well two of the guys that are charged
for the murder two of the guys aren't
for life so they don't give a flying
[ __ ] but the one 27 year old he only had
like 10 years
i thought he was at life no only two
were lifers two of three were lifers the
third one was not really and he but he's
sharp now he is
because um did you beat up an old man
took his eyes out or something
oh but you don't know the details huh
uh-uh
took his tongue in his eyes
well what they like to do with whitey
bulger is uh they put locks and socks
and he's 89 and uh he's confined to a
wheelchair so they can lock into the
wheelchair go and shut that cell door so
nobody can get in and then what they did
is they took the locks and the socks and
beat him
beat him to death but they're not gonna
let you go that easy so then as my boy's
beating you one of the three
what he's gonna do is scoop out your
eyeballs where you're alive sure and
then we're gonna take a knife shank not
a knife and stop
yeah so we're gonna we're gonna take a a
rusty shank and then sever your tongue
off yeah and then continue to beat you
into you so he took his tongue in his
eyes now remember he's 90 right 89. 89
so that's fair he's still in his
eighties basically you don't have to
joe biden yeah yeah and uh so when you
hit that fragile skull
it makes a dead yeah he had some he was
uh so his family suing for 200 million
well there's there's a theory on that
and the judge went like this judge went
like this
there's a conspiracy on that
remember he was an fbi informant correct
knew a lot of [ __ ]
why was he allowed to slip for so long
there's this whole theory oh he's on the
run for 15 years well that that but also
there's a whole theory about why
he got away he basically was put in that
prison
they wanted him to shut the [ __ ] up
because
89
still had some things to say
they knew he'd be taken out yeah but he
can't really get the media out i mean it
makes sense what you're saying i'm just
saying there's not like there's a media
outlet you know it's like it's like a
jack ruby right he was like okay i'm
ready to tell my sorority now i have the
truth like you're good
no no literally i'm gonna tell you what
exactly happened
died of cancer two three months later
wouldn't let him do interviews yeah
i know
so who knows
oh did wouldn't that be weird if the
family won
this is the judge i'm like first of all
whitey bulger dude he killed 11 people
that we know of and they think there's
there's probably 30 more the worst the
worst yeah so hey the guy you're trying
to sue the state for right uh for 200
mil so he killed probably 30 people ran
a whole mafia organization in boston
ruined families cool here's the other
problem he's 90 right so if they didn't
do it something else would get it we're
not giving 200 million right probably
i bet they're gonna be like because he's
90 we'll give you five million yeah
because he's three years definitely you
always you sue for a crazy amount and
you settle out of court yeah city is
settled they have the money presents all
the money what did you get jen
all right so this pastor
wait not this one
this pastor
did a rant
about his the people in his church not
donating enough money so he'd buy his
his favorite watch a movado watch and it
was caught on camera you want a movado
watch he wanted a monster conjugation to
buy it for him yes so this is the video
here
here it is the whole way in august i
still ain't got it y'all ain't saying
nothing let me come down the door and
talk to my cheap sons and daughters
i want to hear no more excuse me what
y'all can't afford you can't afford it
because you don't see the value here
[Music]
y'all hear from your past and father i'm
over y'all
someone said no
please
i'm over your cheap expressions
i know you still broke busted and
disgusted
poor broken disgusting
now movados are two hundred dollars no
they're they get 100 thousands but then
i bought my mom one year it's not like a
rolex right no it's like he's asking for
a [ __ ] daytona but still asking her
oh this whole thing's weird i'm just
saying they could have got the money
together i'm with him on this
i ain't worth your problem
i'm not worth your gucci
[Music]
mother oh i'm saying this and i promise
you digging it is not with respect and
won't i'm saying it because i want you
to understand just what god is saying
people found out that
why are there neon lights behind he's
amazing so here's his apology afterwards
yes
hold on
edition apology
evening
my name is carlton
i'm the senior pastor who triggers the
whale right here in canada
oh man oh man
oh no so i needed to see anything no it
was already crazy i like the whole thing
i spoke to those i am accountable to and
have received their correction and
instruction
i have also privately apologized to a
church
who has extended their love and support
to me
it's a good apology
but i mean you're a jerk
i offer yeah sincere apology to you
today
no context could embrace the words i
used
i apologize to all who have been hurt
angered
or in any way
[Music]
[Music]
do you have to read from the cue card
it's a very very well worded article
better than i can ever he's entertaining
that dude's got a way with language that
[ __ ] don't get some
watch
i want to buy him a month out of
watching find a kid buy one
no do not
watch right now please don't
yeah there we go so this is in
university avenue in orlando
shockingly the
pilot did not die only had money to hit
me [ __ ] cars yeah dude
could you have pulled up a little bit
looks like he was like he lost electric
power maybe that happens with these see
how his his propellers john f k jr he
lost he lost electrical power so we had
to do a crash landing my dad had to do
that he got all [ __ ] uh the plane was
[ __ ] [ __ ] harrison ford did that in
santa monica imagine yeah you live
well i think i didn't hit me [ __ ]
that's exactly what happened to my dad
this but he landed on her yeah do it
so this is in brazil i believe in
video of oh this is an alligator oh this
is on world star wait a minute this guy
went in it's in mexico he went into us
an area where they said uh don't swim
dangerous crocodiles he went i'll be
okay the crocodile went you saw the sign
and now you're out there real crocodile
oh that's a dinosaur
dude what the [ __ ] now your ass up dig
down in the water
look at that [ __ ] right there
see you later nightmare i'm dude
nightmare he's just clearing your body
he wasn't allowed to it's not an
alligator it's a crocodile he wasn't
allowed to swim there what what happened
he was told no you know there's signs
all over they do not swim dangerous
do that yeah
what is this conor mcgregor just getting
weird
is he with a new movement coach
yeah
same breathing coach as luke rockhold
whatever it's doing it's [ __ ] working
he looks great he looks fantastic look
at his quads and hamstrings big guy
i can't wait for him to come back magic
mcgregor huh he's definitely coming back
yeah yeah
somebody sees it like that
what do you think about him posting that
in general ah
nobody's better at taking the hype oh
wait so usman lost people talking about
leon edwards he's chiming in he just
takes everyone's shine yeah oh cool this
woman did exactly what she's supposed to
do when an alligator grabbed an
alligator attacked it's hard she rolled
with it yeah
okay
god get your kid out of there lady
you're the little girl on mommy
did you see your jump to guard yeah
that's very funny it's very smart what's
your guess you gotta guard and roll with
that [ __ ] yeah you roll with it so it
doesn't tear off man well it's going to
pull your hand off that's but also who's
the shitty parent who's like holy [ __ ]
watch this [ __ ] man dude i get all
[ __ ] up
this is crazy this was a guy you seen
this
this is an off-duty police officer i
guess this guy was chasing him and he
like look how hard he tries to hit him
and then the whole caption explains the
story that it was basically like
even if you have a firearm don't think
that you
shooting
at a car that's coming at you is going
to stop it per se you can't be like i
got it boom boom it's just going to like
you know yeah this isn't [ __ ] does he
have to wait
because it comes back and tries to get
him it's a wild little video look at
this
why are they trying to get them
they didn't go into it
but
and he's off duty police officer yep he
just threw it on the ground his phone
you said oh [ __ ] why is this guy so mad
the guy wants to fight him
yeah you have to assume there's
he's being targeted wasn't just a random
thing yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
he's given a lot of opportunities
why was the guy so upset
so then he throws it in drive god why
wouldn't this guy get behind something
oh my god what are you doing dude did
that guy die or
he landed on grass now is he going back
over him
sounds like it feels like
oh he's still doing it
jesus christ so he stayed alive at least
whoo
uh so what happened happened in the back
story
um i'm gonna
read it out right now uh police say the
incident began with brown noticing a man
approaching his vehicle uh his house
and
the guy sped away as brown approached
hitting a car in a mailbox then hill
made his first attempt so there's a
little bit beforehand made his first
attempt to run around over
before hitting a tree
um
that's where the footage picks up but
also that guy why are you staying out
there and get ran over get behind the
tree or something dude
behind your car
and
[Music]
they were finally able to subdue the guy
and he went to the hospital but was
released so i think it's all good damn
they really uh oh that guy's good but
the guy tried to murder him
did he get arrested or yeah they were
able to subdue him
and put him under arrest he didn't catch
a bullet at all
ah that's a good question i don't think
he didn't give an update on whether or
not he got shot yeah
but he was charged with attempted murder
held on bond of a million bucks jesus
christ
so this is a fun one you see he's
chasing this iguana off
i don't know if he's trying to hit it or
whatever
why does he want the iguana so bad oh
well he wants himself an iguana no no
way
[Laughter]
but why kill that he's trying to kill it
who knows dude yeah the weird part is
that he was it looks like he was going
to smash it with a
stick but
someone said brian drunk in montana
on a [ __ ] ferris back
such a good way to get your [ __ ] head
ripped off
that's a dude do him a favor if it
knocked out his teeth
jesus christ he's riding grisly holy
hammered that's some russian [ __ ] uh-huh
i need i need a good old
this is a guy dressed as fbi agent
tries to rob a dispenser owner
[Music]
looks legit right
yeah
no he says
what's going on
man what's going on
for what
i know his teeth are the funny part
what fbi don't have shorts on he gets
shot
he looks like a ups worker oh you come
back
oh i thought this is coming back again
holy [ __ ] he even said like the fbi he
was like the federal building
enforcement or something like that no
one had stood for his teeth he's
terrible hey dog
american police
american forget about an investigator
man
i have a weed police guy give me give me
your weave for the wii u we're
anti-police i'm here for the lead guys
brigade
hey do you have yeezys on and short
[ __ ] what a terrible job you're even
lazy at robbing people [ __ ] hey give me
a wee he sucked you sucked as a criminal
that's it fun show man we haven't been
back in a hot second wow buddy been a
while it has been a while uh for me
tough mudders this saturday in chicago
tough mudder come run with the thick
boys 11 a.m heat use uh code team
brendan get tim's off at sign up mark
harley will be there i'll be there some
of the thick boy staff will be there
come run with the boys 15 k 11 a.m this
mother trucking saturday in chicago uh
tour wise l.a shopping friends august
31st wednesday night 8pm show some
monsters and a very special guest will
be on that that's shaban friends and
hollywood improv but then the real tour
starts appleton wisconsin september 8th
through the 10th that [ __ ] almost sold
out ontario improv ontario california
one of my favorite clubs september 15th
to 17th then i end september in boston
boston laugh boston september 29th
through october 1st get your tickets
thinkboy.com think boy merch drops
friday too it's basically nba uh quality
jersey thick boy jerseys thick boys
shorts and hats that's the boy.com 9am
uh raleigh north carolina good night
september 8th through 10th i apologize i
had to cancel i had to cancel nashville
but i'll be back in march
raleigh north carolina good night
september 8th to the 9th san jose
california improv september 15 1617
spokane washington spokane comedy club
september 22 24. i'm in bridgeport
connecticut's stress factory october
13th through the 15th just go to
briancallen.com uh we uh toe hold has
rash guards uh they got violence solves
everything and don't be a little cuck
which are selling like [ __ ] wildfire
and uh
as always briancallen.com
uh best of on youtube we're coming out
with more episodes i'm coming out with
the uh [ __ ] austin two-parter so
funny and so good sorry it's been a
minute
and uh i'm dropping my own podcast the
brian callan show soon very soon i'll
let you know all right kids love you
this is a fine kid we're out